hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control sc.l
2-3.13.11 employee Phipps validated
cryptography when used to protect the
confidentiality of cui what a nightmare
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 100 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it as I like to say oh the dreaded
Phipps rule yes currently and this may
potentially change in uh nist SP 800171
revision 3 which is due to come out in
23 sometime uh when using encryption to
secure cui you must utilize a fips
validated encryption if that is the only
Safeguard I.E it's not going to be
physically safeguarded as well that's an
important note uh this is not so bad you
guys if your network is within your
secure facility it is physically
protected and does not carry the
requirement so it doesn't apply to
everything but it certainly applies
those key areas such as VPN and wireless
access which cannot be physically
protected
yes there is an article out there where
Microsoft is openly saying that fips may
not even be the most secure or
recommended method of encryption I get
it this is true but it doesn't matter as
this is the current requirement here's a
hint 256-bit AES encryption is fips
140-2 compliant it's available in most
products let's find out more about what
the assessors are looking for on this
one because it's pretty short and simple
they're going to determine if fips
validated cryptography is employed to
protect the content GI of cui our answer
is going to be a template in all cases
where encryption is the only available
Safeguard to protect the confidentiality
of cui that encryption utilized is fips
140-2 uh validated so again
generally speaking most Wireless and VPN
connections already have a 256-bit AES
encryption capability we just need to
make sure that's the one that's selected
and there is an amazing way to make this
one very very easy I know it's very
highly talked about and if you can't
figure it out for your organization
because you've got some interesting
complexities or just really honestly
you're tired of dealing with compliance
and you'd rather us just come do the
heavy lift for you the great news is
that on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this defars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into laps like
a seal on a sunny day we teach you how
to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance has your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you
if you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmmc
complianceecrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance learns
roll it out until the next compliance
tip my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to know
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance and I'll see you
on the next one
[Music]
foreign